well thanksgiving is just two weeks away
everyone
wants and deserves a great holiday meal
they can enjoy with their family but it
can be expensive
help of southern nevada is once again
supplying the need for families who can
barely keep a roof over their heads
right now joan lima
is the community relations manager and
says holidays can be a scary time
i am seeing a lot of fear
that the eviction
moratorium is going to end a lot of fear
that families are going to lose their
homes
they are spending their family resources
on things like rent and utilities
and there's not a lot of resources in
these needy families for
things like holiday toys and extra
purchases for holiday food for
thanksgiving
are you seeing new families in need that
you hadn't seen
before i am because people have been out
of work
for a long time i'm seeing people
applying that
have been out of work since march and
their unemployment has ended
or they've have issues and never
received unemployment we are seeing
families who are doubled up
with uh friends and family we are seeing
multiple families at
the same address in the applications
that we're seeing and also
multi-generations living in the same
room
where you have maybe he would have a
grandparents um an
adult child and then that child had his
or her own children
well help can't supply the need alone so
if you'd like to join their food drive
for holiday side dishes
here's the grocery list of items that
they're going to need by next friday
november 20th
stuffing instant mashed potatoes gravy
canned vegetables of all kinds boxed
macaroni and cheese
canned cranberries desserts such as pie
fillings cake mixes or cookies
they're also collecting turkeys for 900
families
and eight news now will be there to help
that turkey-thon next
week it's at two different smith's
locations one up in sky
canyon that's on thursday and the smiths
on sunset that's next friday
so if you'd like to donate a turkey that
will certainly come in handy and of
course you can always go to their
website to make a donation
at aglpsonv.org
and they will be needing toys and
volunteers to help collect those toys
at the annual toy drive with chet
buchanan that's december 3rd through the
14th
at the nv energy parking lot you know
that's where chet lives up on the
scaffolding
through those cold nights but they
collect so many bicycles and
so many toys and money for help of
southern nevada and other charities so
it's really a great cause
it is great every year and especially
this year people really need it they
sure do
thanks sherry coming